dialogue is not conversation its
conversation with the purpose it's it's
people conversing but every line needs
to move the story forward in some
respect whether it's moving the plot
forward through some sort of revelation
that a character makes or moves these
characters forward in their own
relationship because they have an
argument and that conflict causes one of
them both of them or more of them to
shift in terms of their thought
processes and feelings or it provides
some exposition some information some
data which is a key to help them get a
clue to move the thing forward
but yeah dialogue is conversation but
it's conversation with a purpose you
need to be really mindful of that
so that's tricky because it's got to be
entertaining too
you know and in an ideal world it's more
often than not it's subtextual so that
what's being communicated is really more
about what's underneath the words than
the words themselves it's also dialogue
is also the words that aren't spoken
sometimes the best dialogue is what's
not said so I get the message like is
dialogue conversation and there's a the
subtext there is don't make it just like
how people talk in real life like
because we just go move we just blabber
on and on and on we don't have that
amount of time in a screenplay you need
to be precise and efficient but yes it
is conversational B it should sound
conversational like how characters would
talk in the real world so I get it but
yeah it's conversation with a purpose
that would be my take on that
are there any films that are really a
great study in subtext I would say I
would read anything by Tony Gilroy like
Michael Clayton that script
he doesn't know it he's just he's just
an amazing writer and Michael Clayton is
a really just it's a syrup that anybody
should just read because he not only has
subtext going on but the text is so
entertaining and there's layers to it so
that sometimes he's saying like what's
absolutely on the characters mind so the
text is like right there and so the
words the meaning of the words are right
up top but then there's other layers
underneath too so he's really brilliant
and Michael Clayton is a script I
absolutely recommend
you